with the queen now lying in state a
chance for thousands of mourners to pay
their respects the public can now file
past elizabeth ii's coffin round the
clock until next monday at her state
funeral
many have already done so no phones
allowed in just a moment to reflect
the very first person in had started
queuing on monday meaning two nights
spent outdoors
main
aim is to show respect and
for whatever
great queen has done for the
commonwealth worldwide and
internationally
for 70 odd years
for some in this long queue along the
river thames it was a personal
connection that meant they wanted to be
there
my father was in the guards who did the
coronation of the queen she went down as
princess elizabeth she came back as the
queen of england you know the coronation
so it's a big big thing that she's
passed away
this is brenda traylon getting her
official wristband a guarantee of a
place in the queue she's travelled from
southwest england with memories of
meeting the queen when she got a special
honour
in 2004 she gave me an mbe
for services to the community through
policing and
uh charity work yeah
how did you find it
it was it was
one of the best days of my life and my
parents were still alive to come with me
and my daughter so it was it was
extremely special
on wednesday the archbishop of
canterbury the ceremonial head of the
anglican church was here briefly meeting
mourners
while volunteers representing various
faiths were on hand the trains
we knew that we would be dealing with
people uh who are coming to pay respect
some of whom
will have strong connections to what's
happened to the queen some of whom will
be touching things that go quite deep in
their own experiences of grief
some of whom are there because it's an
important national occasion
of course people are arriving for this
cue to get into westminster hall and
view the queen's coffin all the time and
officials have already warned people
they should be prepared for weights of
up to 30 hours whatever the case people
here are keeping each other in good
spirits and they're making friends as
well
whatever their motivation thousands of
people are determined to get their
chance to say goodbye to the late
monarch ahead of her funeral an event
that could draw as many as a million
people onto the streets nadine barber al
jazeera london